well today almost four years after
Britain voted for brexit the UK is
finally set to leave the European Union
the historic day has been greeted with
some triumphant headlines in Britain but
not everyone is celebrating as Britain
ends its 47 year membership of the EU
the country's future remains uncertain
Mark Phillips is outside the houses of
parliament in London mark what happens
now it has been a long goodbye this
business of the UK leaving the European
Union and it's not over yet officially
the UK is out at 11:00 p.m. here tonight
but this is less the end of what seemed
like an endless process as the starting
gun for what comes next it's been an
emotional farewell for some members of
the European Parliament in Brussels sang
auld lang syne for departing British
members but the UK will continue to pay
membership dues and follow EU rules for
the next year while a new trade deal is
worked out if it is freedom democracy it
was a gloating goodbye for Nigel Faraj
the British politician who has made it
his life's work to get the UK out of
Europe put your flags away you're
leaving Prime Minister Boris Johnson
says brexit will unleash Britain's
potential others say it will diminish
Britain and placed a love note on the
White Cliffs of Dover facing France the
winners and losers and the brexit battle
will hold respective rallies here today
for the winners the celebration for the
losers awake the battle may be over but
Anthony the arguments go on sure do mark
Phillips in London thanks